il n'y a aucun moyen que nous puissions vivre ici, viens sur
leur ligne électrique, détends-toi
Je n'ai pas senti le Jimmer grouiller partout
là-bas personne n'a de tumeurs
Oh ralentis s'il te plait j'ai un
vendeur très motivé
tu veux dire vérifier la tour incarnée
à je pense
qu'il y a un fort à venir arrêtez d'être
un tel ruban de bébé
j'ai peur comment allez-vous arriver ici à qui
parlez-vous nous ne savions pas où
aller d'autre vous avez fait la bonne chose en venant à
nous cela ne semble pas  être une hantise classique,
cela ne ressemble à rien de ce que j'ai
vu auparavant, c'est un nouveau poltergeist plus puissant
Maddy, nous avons besoin que vous
reveniez vers nous maintenant, chérie,
videz-vous l'esprit, ils savent déjà ce qui
vous fait peur,
quelque chose ne va pas